en su séptima alocución desde el
comienzo de la pandemia de manuela optó
por defender las medidas que ha venido
tomando a lo largo de este año y dio un
voto de confianza a los franceses para
poder seguir sorteando toda esta
situación el presidente optó no por no
volver a confinar de manera estricta en
el país pero sí a extender las medidas
que están en vigor en diecinueve de los
departamentos a todo el territorio
metropolitano a partir de este sábado y
por espacio de cuatro semanas el toque
de queda comenzará de siete de la noche
a seis de la mañana no habrá
desplazamientos entre regiones a menos
de tener un motivo de fuerza mayor el
teletrabajo es digamos la regla en la
medida por supuesto de lo posible y
solamente podrán abrir sus puertas los
comercios esenciales en cuanto a la
saturación hospitalaria actualmente hay
siete mil camas de reanimación y estos
pasarán a 10.000 dentro de las próximas
semanas además de esto también habrá
apoyo por parte de la reserva sanitaria
para venir a ayudar
en los hospitales como digamos mano de
obra en cuanto a los colegios éstos
cerrarán a partir del próximo lunes por
espacio de 13 semanas la próxima semana
será clases a distancia luego serán 12
semanas de vacaciones de primavera y se
espera que los estudiantes ya que sea
desde preescolar hasta elíseo incluyendo
también las guarderías vuelvan poco a
poco a partir del próximo 26 de abril
para el presidente macro es la
vacunación la que va a ayudar a salir de
esta crisis 1.700 puntos de vacunación
en todo el país para las vacunas pzifer
y modernas y más de 250.000
profesionales de la salud además de
bomberos e incluso veterinarios que
pueden aplicar la vacuna de astrazéneca
y muy pronto la de johnson y josh
presidente terminó su alocución con una
noticia que puede dar un poco de aliento
a los franceses en este momento y es que
espera que a mediados de mayo el país
pueda volver a comenzar a abrir los
lugares culturales los museos los cines
los teatros y también los bares y los
restaurantes sobre todo en las